[Applause]
happy Thursday everyone I'm Kat Tim
filling in for Greg because he's making
out with a mirror so how was your summer
that's great or that's terrible
depending on whatever you just said to
the TV
mine's been busy because I've been on
tour it's been a great year for blonde
women who yell during air travel
since July I've been to nine different
cities from Midland Texas to St Louis
Missouri and I still have 13 more to go
before the end of the year but don't
worry this isn't going to be a monologue
where I just repeat over and over again
that tickets to all my shows are
available now at the realcattemp.com
I want to talk about what I've learned
visiting so many different parts of the
country for one going to the continental
breakfast in just pajama bottoms in a
bra is frowned upon even at a motel 6.
anyway to be clear all these places are
different in St Louis I talked with an
Uber driver about how cool it is that
Nelly and Ashanti are back together
in Texas my Uber driver said what's an
Ashanti
but I've learned that as different as
all these conversations were all of them
were a lot different from the stuff that
you hear people talking about on the
news
I know what you're thinking cat you work
in the news what are you doing you're
gonna get fired but don't worry if I
didn't get fired for that time Judge
Jeanine caught me in her office trying
on her shoes I probably won't get fired
for this either
especially because I think it's really
important to talk about Gallup poll data
earlier this month found that political
polarization has widened on some issues
30 percentage points or more between
Republicans and Democrats over the last
two decades my first thought Noda but
even though it might not be surprising
it also low-key sucks
I know that it's not like things are so
contentious for no reason the arrest of
a former president and current
Republican front-runner for example
isn't going to be something people see
and just go meh
I'm not stupid regardless of what some
of your grandmas tell me in the Facebook
comments
and by the way it's spelled t-o-o skinny
not t-o
but because I'm not stupid I also
understand that it's far easier for the
government to gain power over us the
more divided that we are especially
because Americans hate math
but it can play us against each other
and make us afraid and it makes it
easier for them to convince us to give
up our rights
remember the Patriot Act it remembers
everything about you
if you don't the government doesn't care
as long as it gets to conduct
surveillance on you without a warrant
most of you guys have been on camera as
much as I have in the past few years and
you'd even get to go to hair and makeup
first
but also writing off an entire person
over a disagreement on a single
political issue might mean you could be
missing out on some really awesome
things about that person
for example
Jesse Waters voted for Trump I voted for
Joe Jorgensen but I have no idea where I
would be without Jesse's advice on where
I should buy my hair pieces
living in a bubble is always easier
especially with an immune system like
mine
but much like a degree from Devry easier
isn't always better
that's why on my tour I do insist on
going to so many different places I've
seen so many things I didn't expect to
see like a man walk up to me during a
meet and greet and say I bet I'm your
only priest fan
yeah a priest is a fan of me
all my years of being an altar server
finally paid off I'm not joking look at
the photo that's me
I recorded a video for a 15 year old
girl in St Louis because her parents
told me that she was upset she couldn't
join because she had school the next day
I told her she's almost old enough to
drop out
I told an old lady in Alabama that I
liked her shoes and she excitedly told
me that they were Michael Kors and that
she got them for the show I almost
started crying because it was so cute
and I still think about how she's doing
especially since I made her give me her
shoes
oh also in Alabama a lesbian with a neck
tattoo offered me her number
I said cool I will give this to Joe
Mackey for you
anyway at first I wondered how are all
of these different people coming to see
the same show
but then I realized it's because we have
far more in common than politicians and
media want us to think and it's proven
two things to me one all the people
coming to my shows are not mad at me
thank God
two whether you live in Midland Texas or
St Louis Missouri or Detroit Michigan my
favorite city in the entire world I
can't wait to go home and do two shows
in Detroit on October 7th and 8th
there's some stuff that you probably
care about you probably want to be happy
you probably love your family and your
friends and you probably have that one
friend that's a pain in the ass but
you're in way too deep to get out now
actually a survey published earlier this
summer found that about 9 out of 10
Democrats and Republicans agreed on the
importance of core values like personal
responsibility fairness and compassion
but only about a third believe that the
other side thought those things were
important
it's not that I don't understand the
Temptation especially with something
like personal responsibility how can you
say you value personal responsibility if
you want the government to wipe your ass
and it's fine to debate but when you
debate someone on an issue remember that
that's what you're doing debating on an
issue you might think the other person's
view is bad but that doesn't mean the
person is bad
maybe unless the person's view is this
what do you think about yourself
yeah I like icers
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests alcohol
gets hung over from her Fox News anchor
Julie Banderas
Hair Clubs for men wants him to be their
spokesperson Washington Times opinion
editor and Fox News contributor Charlie
hurts
if laughter is the best medicine his act
is a placebo writer and comedian Joe
DeVito
and when he wants to relax he chills out
on cloud nine New York Times bestselling
author comedian and former NWA world
champion Tyron
alrighty so I mean okay Tyrus I mean
you've you my friend have lived a
bajillion different lives lived in a lot
of places you're a bouncer you're a
wrestler now you're at Fox News so go
ahead what are your thoughts well I
thought you made a great point about
we never hear about what we have in
common yeah and touring the country and
that's one of the things I think gives
me an advantage I'm always called The
Common Sense guy because I know
everybody like when you rest all over
the country or do stand-up shows over
the country or whoever it is you meet
all kinds of people different walks of
lives but it's always the same core
thing it's like they want they want the
roof over their head they want food in
their bellies they prefer no one
breaking in the middle of the night and
they want to get along with their
neighbors that's literally what
everybody wants and so but we never hear
that we hear every little thing that
gets stressed out or they take something
that's not really true and they expand
it and make it bigger and try to fear
among us but that is a phenomenal Point
like if we take the time to meet the
person next to us like at a show like
this you will find that you have a lot
in common not just the fact that you're
enjoying a show and want to laugh but
then if you went to I don't know if you
went to the view show and before you got
into the cage fight you might find the
things that you guys eat at the same
restaurant every once in a while so have
some common ground take some risks and
maybe when someone starts talking about
I can't believe you voted for Trump and
you can say well I can't believe you
those shoes those are awesome where did
you get them yeah yeah exactly change
the change the narrative so Julie I'm
going to give you a choice okay you can
either say something nice about Joe
Biden or you can say something nice
about Joe DeVito
I think Joe Biden's face is looking
pretty good
honestly if you think about it he's 80.
and his his skin is tight yeah
um I think his plastic surgeons should
be given around Ben is still on his body
I also believe right before the show Joe
was actually using tape to keep his
shirt from opening to show Too Much
chest hair so I don't think Joe Biden
has that problem no there's a lapel you
couldn't just sit you know what I say to
that what do you do that
hahaha
Julie what are your thoughts
people have more in common than than we
believe or want to admit to but I think
people are too stuck in politics who
gives a crap what you voted for if
anyone starts calling talking politics
to me I'm out but I think just people
used to need to use more common sense
and be more real I think a lot of people
are very fake if you're real and
yourself I think you'll have something
to talk about with the person sitting
next to you don't talk to each other
here though because that would be very
rude yeah
all right Joe so my next two shows are
in Texas but then after that I'm going
to Portland
good luck good luck see that's what
everybody says but I don't want to limit
where I can go and connect with people
and also I'm bringing Kennedy so I feel
like whatever's going on there the
weirdest thing that's going on there
will be the two of us on stage yeah
that's not the order I would do those
two towns finish with the yeah it's nice
that you know we a lot of we travel
around I love seeing what it's like in
different parts of the country some
parts of the country call uh shoes
sneakers other parts of the country call
them tennis shoes and some parts of the
country women prefer pepper spray other
parts they prefer mace it's uh you gotta
look for the commonalities is what I
think you know like well it's like where
they say that um human beings share
sometimes you're someone say we share 95
of our DNA with with apes and whenever I
hear that I think that person wants a
monkey uh
interesting
um
no follow-up there no I I just I suppose
I never thought of it that way uh that's
a first for all of us yeah Charlie is
there polarization on your farm
no and there's also science Reigns
nobody's confused about gender on a farm
uh it can be kind of rough for some of
the animals
um if you're a female chicken if you're
a hen things can be a little rough uh
especially when it's time to go to into
the coop and the roosters get a little
Randy
um you you start to really appreciate
Law and Order because
Law and Order is what prevents uh you
know is what brings order to to society
uh but I think you're all your your
opening is exactly right you know and I
think that you know that you have two
main culprits you have the media who uh
exploit the the differences and do
everything they can to to divide people
but politicians especially in Washington
do so much you know they always you know
they're always running making promises
to fix problems and they never fix them
and the reason they never fix them is
because they they would never be able to
run on their next election if they fix
them yeah and and so and so we as people
have to learn to uh hold them
accountable when they don't fix things
and and I think we're sort of at the end
stages where and I quite frankly I think
it's where so much of the politics about
the weather now Democrats are going to
fix the weather they're going to fix the
weather because they haven't been able
to fix anything else that they've been
promising for decades that they're going
to fix
um and we have to uh we we need to find
our commonality and hold them
accountable can I see them real quick
when you go to Portland you're going to
get nothing but love yeah because I've
been there and I'm doing a show in
California ooh California it sold out in
like two weeks and I'd do another one
like don't be confused with that there's
Republicans everywhere you can always
find them they arms across like Julie's
and they're usually going this is
ridiculous but that but they're there
and let's not say hey there's some weird
stuff on Farm oh yeah especially like
the young the young males they start
humping air and get lost and confused
there's all kinds of fun stuff to watch
you'd love it since the monkey thing so
check it out yeah you also don't have to
be a republican to enjoy my show you
should be a human though all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else